at berlin gap on the sussex coast the
sea continues its relentless march
coastal erosion has long been a
challenge here but climate change is
accelerating the damage
kate and graham harris stayed in a hotel
on the cliff top for their honeymoon
more than 30 years ago it's much closer
to the ocean now than it was back then
i guess you realize that it is eroding
and that you know we are losing
our landscape because it is disappearing
into the sea and actually in you don't
imagine that you see it in your lifetime
but this isn't just a local problem
in england alone there are more than
five million homes and properties at
risk from coastal river or surface water
flooding and as sea levels rise and
extreme weather becomes more frequent
the number of people in harm's way is
likely to increase
at the moment according to data from the
environment agency hull is among the
most at-risk areas for coastal erosion
it's been estimated that up to 58 meters
of shoreline could be lost over the next
20 years if no action is taken to
prevent it and elsewhere in england up
to 40 meters could be lost in places
such as shoreham by sea lansing worthing
and liverpool
the threat has prompted this stark
warning
in the long term
climate change means that some of our
communities both in this country and
around the world
cannot stay where they are
it is simply too early to predict which
communities will be affected many of
course will be kept safe by flood
defenses and other adaptations but some
places like fairborn in wales have
already been told that the council can't
hold back the water forever
there is unfortunately not enough
funding to go around to protect
communities from flooding and coastal
erosion everywhere and so the importance
is about having that early and honest
conversation and working with
communities to make sure that their
voices are heard
despite billions of pounds in planned
spending on flooding the government has
always known there will be a limit to
how much it can do
the forces driven by climate change far
too powerful
hannah thomas peter sky news in sussex